Hardly anything runs in our
society today without microchips.
They are the heart of cell
phones, computers, cars.
A chip is made up of transistors: tiny switches
10,000 times smaller than a human hair that
control the flow of electrons through a circuit.
Billions of transistors are packed
into an area smaller than a fingernail.
Microchips are one of humankind’s
most remarkable achievements.
And it wouldn’t be possible to make the
world’s most sophisticated chips
without the German company ZEISS.
In a previous video, I talked about how the
Dutch firm ASML is the only company in the
world that builds the machines that create
the circuitry for the most advanced chips.
These machines wouldn’t be able to operate
without ZEISS mirrors inside of them.
These are not your average mirrors.
They’re a complex optical
system that miniaturizes the
structure of a chip printed on a silicon wafer.
Light is projected through a blueprint
of the pattern that will be printed.
ZEISS optics focus the pattern onto the wafer,
which has already been coated
with a light-sensitive chemical.
It shrinks the pattern down to the nanometer
level. A nanometer is one billionth of a meter!
In the end, the wafer is cut
into small pieces of microchips.
While ASML’s less advanced chipmaking
machines use lenses to focus light,
lenses won’t work for its most advanced
lithography machines because these
machines use Extreme Ultraviolet
light, which lenses would absorb.
EUV is a shorter wavelength of light than that
used by conventional chip-making machines.
EUV light can help pack more transistors
onto a chip, making the chip more powerful.
Since Zeiss cannot use lenses for the
most advanced machines, it uses mirrors.
A series of ultra-reflective curved mirrors
guide the light in a vacuum chamber.
The mirrors need to be extremely flat because even
the smallest irregularity leads to imaging errors.
We’re not talking about your
typical level of smoothness.
They are HYPER smooth. Polished to
a thickness of less than one atom!
What does that even mean?
Well, if you were to enlarge the mirror
to the size of Germany, then the tallest
mountain would be less than 1 mm high!
ZEISS makes the flattest mirrors on earth.
They are held in a position as precisely
as possible during the exposure process.
They are so stable that if a ZEISS
mirror were to redirect a laser beam
and aim it at the moon, it would be able
to hit a ping pong ball on its surface!
ASML knows just how crucial
ZEISS is to its entire operation.
It’s no wonder that in 2016, ASML bought
a billion-euro stake in a subsidiary
of Zeiss, Carl Zeiss SMT, purchasing
24.9% of the shares of Carl Zeiss SMT.
ZEISS and ASML pretty much have no rivals.
Every one of the most advanced chips on
Earth has passed through their system.
They supply Taiwan Semiconductor Manufacturing
Company that produces over 90% of the world’s
most advanced chips. TSMC makes 5 nm chips and
is striving to make even smaller 3 nm ones.
The strategic partnership between Zeiss
and ASML means the barrier to entry for
potential competitors is exceedingly high.
Other manufacturers could try to build
their own EUV lithography machines.
However, if China does want to build a
machine that could rival Zeiss and ASML’s,
analysts believe it would take at
least 10 years for them to do so.
Trouble is, China cannot access the most
advanced equipment from Zeiss and ASML right now.
Because the Trump administration pressed ASML hard
to block sales of its most advanced
EUV lithography machines to China.
And the Biden administration has
broadened chip restrictions against
Beijing which I discussed in a previous
video that I’ll link in my description.
Since ZEISS was founded by German
entrepreneur Carl Zeiss in the mid-1800s,
it has since grown to secure THE
advantage in optics on the world stage.
Yet it’s not sitting comfortably.
ZEISS is already working on next-generation
optics to by increasing the numerical aperture.
The numerical aperture is a measure of how much
light the optical system can collect and focus.
The increase in the numerical aperture
will significantly improve the resolution.
Improving the resolution will increase the number
of transistors that can be packed onto
the chip, making it even more powerful.
And as our future moves toward autonomous driving,
artificial intelligence, and 5G and beyond
- you can bet there will be demand for ever
more powerful processors and
the machines that make them.
Building the world’s most
powerful lenses and mirrors
would not be possible without talented engineers.
If you’d like to improve your math, science,
and computer science skills to help build the
future or simply for your own personal pleasure,
Brilliant is a great way to
brush up on your STEM skills.
I know my viewers especially love the Scientific
Thinking course, where you can explore the
center of mass interactively or make a bridge as
rigid as possible with as few beams as possible.
Another course that my viewers enjoy
is Computer Science Fundamentals,
where you can build algorithms and navigate
drones to their proper destination.
I personally love their Logic courses.
In this exercise I'm working on,
you have to put things in the correct order.
If you ever get stuck you can
view the explanation for more.
Brilliant is great whether you’re a student or
you’re a professional already in the workforce.
And it’s FREE for you to try out with
my custom link in the description:
brilliant.org/newsthink.
That’s brilliant.org/newsthink.
The first 200 people to sign up
with my custom link will get 20%
off Brilliant’s annual Premium
subscription which gives you
access to all of their course offerings
including their most advanced courses.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.